the dance of dragons a true telling' by
grand mr. Monken being a history of the
war of Targaryen succession between the
princess rhaenyra and aegon ii of his
name that nearly destroyed the realm the
dance of the Dragons a stupid name for a
Targaryen Civil War where my ancestors
danced away my birthright
before the war House Targaryen counted
18 dragons by the end we had to and
nearly as few Targaryen 's we would
never be as powerful or as feared again
the dance began as many dancers do with
an old man and a young girl the Queen
had failed to produce a son for her king
so he anointed his daughter the princess
rhaenyra as his heir but years later the
king remarried and his new wife queen
alicent of house Hightower gave him a
son feeble and foolish the old king
refused to change the succession he
didn't even see how is called had split
into two rival camps of blacks and
greens after the dresses of the princess
and the Queen had worn to some Tony
one night a servant found the old king
had died in his sleep and ran to inform
queen alicent protocol dictated that the
bells would be rung and a raven sent to
Dragonstone to some in the air princess
rhaenyra for her coronation but allison
had other plans once she saw her dead
husband's body she sealed the room and
had a servant thrown into the black
cells to ensure his silence at the hour
of the owl the Lord Commander of the
Kingsguard so Kristen Cole summoned the
small council to inform them of the
King's death so Otto Hightower the hand
of the king and father to queen alicent
demanded that the succession be settled
immediately the decrepit old men of the
small council were confused the
succession was settled in their minds
the old king had forced the lords of
westeros to swear fealty to princess
rhaenyra as his heir
but Sir Kristen Cole rightly pointed out
that her son comes before a daughter the
council argued until dawn when the
master of coin finally stood up and
declared he would have no part of
treason so Kristen Cole wisely opened
his throat with a dagger ending the
debate none were more surprised to hear
of Prince Aegon succession than Prince
Aegon himself at first the fool rejected
the crown but his mother pointed out
that his sister rhaenyra would return
such loyalty by taking his head as the
old King's trueborn son he'd always be a
threat
eggwin relented he was crowned in the
dragon pit and his wife and sister
helena became queen his brother Amon
flew off to win over the few great Lords
who support Aegon didn't already have
the banner of the gold dragon flew over
King's Landing in the red key as Aegon
second of his name ascended the iron
throne he would not sit at long when
Ravens carried the news of a Gunn's
coronation to dragonstone princess
rhaenyra summoned her own black council
with her was her uncle and husband
daemon targaryen considered by many to
be the most dangerous man in Westeros
few Lords supported her but the greatest
of these was Corliss valerian who
controlled the largest fleet in the rail
and his Targaryen wife Rhaenys the old
king sister then there were her five
sons although none grown to manhood a
pitiful assembly really combined they
couldn't match the power of house
Hightower alone but rhaenyra had dragons
she Damon and Rhaenys rode huge and
formidable beasts and three of her five
sons were riders as well Dragonstone
also held six more dragons without
riders against this King Aegon had only
four dragons of his own dragons can burn
a city but only armies can take and hold
it if she was to prevail rhaenyra
desperately needed the support of the
few Great Houses not already swarmed to
Aegon her eldest son Jake Eris flew to
the Vale in the north her middle son
Luke Aerys flew to the Stormlands
rhaenyra hoped that the war would begin
and if the gods were good end with
diplomacy as always they weren't little
prince Luke Aerys must have wet himself
when he entered storm's end and found
king aegon's younger brother Aymond
already with Lord Baratheon Amon was
fearsome even before he lost his eye and
set a sapphire in his stead but the
princeling pleaded his mother's case
finally Lord Baratheon made his decision
go on pop and tell the [ __ ] Your Mother
that the Lord of storms end is not a dog
she can whistle up as a man's false eye
at him the princeling fled the casstle
and mounted his young dragon clerics the
rain fell in sheets and great bolts of
lightning lit the world brightest day
Erick's were struggling to stay aloft in
the gale
when a roll shook the very foundations
of storms end
Amon rose through the clouds and below
him the monstrous Vega Veigar was five
times the size of Eric's and the
hardened survivor of a hundred battles
veigar caught him above shipbreaker bay
Watchers on the castle walls saw distant
blasts of flame and heard a shriek drown
out the Thunder prinsloo caressed fell
broken to be swallowed by the waves with
his death the war
Ravens came to an end and the war of
fire and blood began when rhaenyra heard
of her son's death she collapsed she
considered ending the war right then
until a raven arrived from her husband
daemon her son would be avenged
whispers slithered through the taverns
and back alleys of flea bottom two men
were found one was a former gold cloak
the other a ratcatcher in the red keep
who knew all its secrets history
remembers them only as blood and cheese
one night queen helaena
entered the royal apartments with her
daughter and two sons to put them to bed
without warning blood and cheese
bursting daggers in hand they told her
that a debt was owed a son for a son
blood and cheese demanded she choose
which son would be ripped from her
forever queen helaena
pleaded with the man to kill her instead
but they refused weeping Hellena named
her younger son Melo
perhaps she thought the boy was too
young to understand perhaps because the
older boy was king aegon's
firstborn son and heir you hear that
little boy
she's whispered to the younger son your
mama wants you dead
then blood struck off the older boy's
head with a single blow when the guards
burst in they found queen helaena
still screaming clasping her dead son's
body to her mad with grief the blood of
their children transformed a dynastic
dispute into a war of annihilation the
grief and rage of losing a child could
burn down the world either egg on or
aneri could live at the end but not both
rhaenyra's forces struck yet another
blow the moment the lord of harrenhal
saw daemon targaryen circling the castle
on his dragon caraxes he struck his
banners and surrendered the blanks now
had the strongest castle in the
Riverlands darker news still came to
Aegon thanks to rhaenyra's son's
Winterfell had declared for rhaenyra as
had the veil furious Aegon dismissed his
grandfather sir otto his hand and
appointed so Kristen Cole who swore to
march on all the lords were declared for
rhaenyra and put their castles to the
torch coal and the royal army first
marched north and laid siege to rooks
rest a black stronghold near Dragonstone
when the Lord saw their approach he sent
a raven to rhaenyra begging for help for
days he watched his fields and villages
burning with no response from his queen
until one day a shadow passed over the
green army rhaenyra had sent not an army
but her former mother by law reigns and
her dragon Malins as her ancestor had
done
field of fire Rhaenys gleefully began to
incinerate sacristans army with a gone
and set a trap a trainees had flown
right into it
as Rainey's and Malee's blanketed
sacristans troops and dragon flame to
other dragons rose into the sky Amon Don
Vega and King Aegon himself on the
gleaming Sun fire to her credit Rainey
didn't flee dragon fought dragons and
his second son blossomed in the sky when
the smoke cleared only Aymond and veigar
stood uninjured son fire the most
magnificent dragon in the world had one
of its wings almost completely torn from
its body trapped beneath Sun fire was
the king himself broken and burned so
badly in places that his armor had fused
onto his flesh his body survived but his
mind was given over to milk of the poppy
Malee's had been torn to shreds and her
rider Rainey's was a pile of ash
panicked by the defeat Rainier has
shipped her two youngest sons across the
Narrow Sea for their protection only
fair youngest to return days later
clinging to the neck of his wounded and
dying dragon he and his brother had been
set upon by an enemy fleet just off
dragon stone defying his mother's
command rhaenyra's eldest son and heir
Jake Harris mounted his dragon vormax
and flew to rescue his other brother and
punish the enemy fleet but the foolish
boy let vormax be hooked like a trout
and dragged into the sea where he soaked
up even more arrows and sea water his
brother disappeared over the horizon or
beneath the waves no one could say for
sure
with the loss of four dragons Ramirez
only advantage was fading luckily for
her
over the centuries House Targaryen had
spilled more than blood on Dragonstone
she promised gold and title to any of
the Targaryen bastards who could tame
the six unclaimed dragons on the island
these bastards were called the dragon
seeds though most were called supper
then perhaps the Dragons were eventually
sated or bored but four of them accepted
riders and were enlisted in rhaenyra's
cause after rooks rest a man wanna I
took command of the greens from his
crippled and poppy addled brother Amon
was the blood of the dragon and dragons
don't cower behind city walls he marched
the king's army north to take back
Harrenhal from rhaenyra's husband daemon
but when he and Kristen Cole reached the
castle they found the gates open with
daemon and all his men gone that night
they feasted their victory Damon had
fled rather than faced their wrath the
daemon was more snake than dragon as a
man marched north he'd flown carracks
east south slithering past the green
army over the waters of the gods eye on
day King's Landing looked up and saw two
dragons circling their foul City Damon
and rhaenyra had come for
for the city was defenseless Ament had
taken the king's army from the city and
worse he taken his dragon Vega seeing
the resistance was hopeless
the small council surrendered the city
the Queen Mother alicent and the broken
queen helaena but not King Aegon somehow
despite his wounds and delirium he had
vanished from the city and so queen
rhaenyra climbed the steps and seated
herself on the Iron Throne
legend has it that as she left the hall
later blood trickled down her legs and
hens proving the Iron Throne had spurned
her nonsens it's a chair made of steel
blades
rhaenyra had wanted it all her life and
it's sacrificed two suns for it
she likely gripped the damn thing too
tight when Aymond realized that his
arrogance had cost him the capital he
mounted veigar in a black rage and
rained fire onto every village and
castle he suspected of disloyalty
abandoned by Aymond to christen marched
the royal army back to King's Landing
intent on recapturing the city himself
instead he was trapped and cut to pieces
by the river Lords who had sworn to
support rhaenyra's claim when a new army
of green loyalists marked up from the
reach and laid siege to the city of
tumble ttan rhaenyra sent two of her
dragon seeds to lay waste to them
instead the dragon seed proved their
bastard nature and betrayed her they
burned the city and all the black forces
garrisoned within lucky for her they
didn't turn towards King's Landing but
horde and drank in the ruins with the
greens who were victorious and somewhat
confused
Rainie are now mistrusted all the dragon
seeds including the girl who rode with
her husband daemon hunting Aymond in the
Riverlands she ordered the girl's head
be sent to her but there was a
complication as well as her dragon
the girl had taken to writing daemon
when Damon received the Queen's order he
proclaimed at a Queen's words and a
horse work
he sent the girl away at dawn watching
her and her dragon vanish into the
morning mists then Damon sent the
challenge to his nephew Aymond and flew
to Harrenhal alone to wait 14 days later
the shadow blacker than any passing
clouds swept over Harrenhal
Veigar had come at last and on her back
road one eye prince aemond he mocked the
demon for facing him alone you have
lived too long uncle and Damon replied
on that much we agree then the old
prince climbed stiffly onto the back of
his dragon caraxes but neglected to
fasten the chains that secured rider to
son the son was close to setting when as
one the two dragons left into the sky
Damon took our axes up swiftly until
they disappeared into a bank of clouds
Veigar older and slow ascended more
gradual
up-and-up Veigar sword searching for
currencies sudden as a thunderbolt a
shrieking crack seized over bond Vegard
locked together the dragon stumbled
toward the lake corrects his jaws closed
about vague arsenic but Vega raked open
cracks his belly and her teeth ripped
off a wing lay crushed up with terrible
speed then daemon targaryen court never
fastened his writing chains stood in his
saddle he left from his dragon to Amin's
and in his hand was dark sister the
Valyrian sword of a cons sister queen
Visenya as amon one i looked up in
terror daemon ripped off his nephews
helm and drove the sword down into his
one remaining eye so hard the point came
out the back of the young prince's
throat half a heartbeat later the
Dragons struck the lake sending up a
gout of water so high that it was said
to have been as tall as Haran halls
great tower the lake boiled with dragon
blood and then was still daemon
targaryen was 9 and 40 at his death
prince aemond had only turned 20 Veigar
the greatest of the Targaryen dragons
had counted 181 years
thus past the last living creature from
the days of Aegon's conquest back in
King's Landing queen rhaenyra didn't
have much time to grieve for her stupid
husband the mad former queen helaena
flung herself from a balcony to be
impaled upon the iron spikes lining the
moat of mega was hold fast that night
the city rose in riot against rhaenyra
demanding justice for queen helaena and
her murdered son among other foolish
peasant fantasies in the midst of this
chaos a one-handed fool called the
Shepherd began to rant against dragons
not just the ones of the enemy but all
dragons everywhere as he pointed to the
dragon pit above on the hill he shouted
there the demons dwell this is their
city if you would make it yours
first you must destroy them cry went up
from 10,000 throats
kill them there were four dragons housed
within the dragon pit that night by the
time the first of the attackers came
pouring in all four were roused awake
and angry nobody knows how many men and
women died that night who cares they all
should have trapped within the pit the
Dragons could not fly instead they
formed with horns claws teeth and fire
for every man who died ten war appeared
shouting that the Dragons must die one
by one they did finally the last
remaining dragon broke her chains spread
her wings and flew straight up at the
Great Dome trying to flee already
weakened by dragon flame the dome
cracked under the force of impact and
then tumbled down crushing dragon
slayers and herself
high atop the red keep queen rhaenyra
clutched her two remaining sons to her
as she watched the end of a family's
might too afraid of the peasants to
defend her dragons at least her older
son Joffrey had a man's spine he stole
his mother's dragons Cyrax
and tried to fly it to the dragon pit to
save his birthright the stupid beasts
didn't understand and twist it beneath
him fighting to be free of the little
boy until it was a queen is still a
woman with all the weakness of that
sexes weeping for her lost son more than
her dragons rhaenyra abandoned the iron
throne and sold her crown to buy passage
for her and her last son back to
Dragonstone
rhaenyra hoped to hatch more dragons
from the eggs in the castle but when she
landed the welcoming party slew her
guards and marched her and her son at
spear point to the castle to face a dead
man and a dying dragon sister King Aegon
second of his name called out to reign
era rooks rest had left Aegon bent and
twisted his once handsome face puffy
from milk of the poppy with burn scars
covering half his body
rhaenyra ever defiant told her dear
brother that she'd hoped he was dead
after you Aegon answered
then Sunfire bathe her in a blast of
flame and devoured her in six bites or
the son watched leading the seventh and
final bite her lower leg for the
stranger
rhaenyra was dead and king aegon sat the
iron throne again but only for half a
year he was poisoned by his own men and
replaced with the very boy who had
watched his mother devoured
when Rheneas lasts unwed Agron's only
daughter the dance of dragons officially
ended passion burned men all that was
left of the revelant - scared children
spouting oaths they didn't understand
all that was left of the mighty House
Targaryen ancient skulls and hatch
things that grew no bigger than cats all
was left of the Dragons